we are going to be on tour for the rest
of this year and we are coming to a
city near you
here are all the cities that we are
coming to
on this tour they are seattle washington
portland oregon are two of my favorites
indianapolis indiana morgantown west
virginia munhall
pennsylvania washington dc new york new
york atlantic city new jersey rochester
new york iowa city iowa madison
wisconsin louisville kentucky los
angeles california bakersfield
california reading pennsylvania atlanta
georgia st louis missouri fresno
california sacramento california san
francisco california garden city idaho
and then finally
new year's eve toronto ontario you can
get your tickets at
timdylandcomedy.com
promo code is fake biz okay
this is important because we're putting
them on sale
pre-sale
will allow you to get tickets
uh before the public
the password or the pre-sale code is
fake biz
b f-a-k-e-b-i-z z
this all starts tomorrow
monday september 13th at 12 p.m eastern
standard time you can unlock tickets for
this tour we're very excited about it
and we look forward to seeing you guys
on the road tickets go on sale to the
public on wednesday september 15th at 10
a.m local time but pre-sale live this
monday tomorrow at 12 p.m promo code
fake biz
f-a-k-e-b-i-z ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the tim dillon show we are
uh struggling with the new vaccine
mandate in our company
our company only has two people
but ben the other day produced a fake
vaccine card
and he has been reported
um
no in all seriousness the vaccine
mandate affecting companies with over
100 people
uh this is a federal mandate i believe
states are resisting it they're suing
um
the vaccine mandates i don't understand
you can get covet if you're vaccinated
you could spread covet if you're
vaccinated uh if you've had covert
already and you have antibodies there
are studies and articles that show uh
that those antibodies are more powerful
than the vaccine and they are
um
they're longer lasting
united airlines staff who are granted
religious exemptions to vaccine mandate
will be put on unpaid leave what would
those religious exemptions be
uh what would that uh it's got to be
mormon probably right because
well christian scientists don't take any
medication that's true that's true
the airline last month said 67 000
person uh u.s workforce must be
vaccinated against covet this fall but
said it would consider exemptions for
religious
and personal beliefs
as well as medical reasons well personal
beliefs that would include everybody
right right well
okay
i don't get the mandates i think that uh
this should be
voluntary um i got the vaccine i was
pitched
um like everything america makes i was
pitched a slightly different version of
the product than the one i actually got
the version i was pitched was the one
that kept you from getting covered
that is not the product that showed up
uh in the mail
uh
yes i didn't die when i got it which is
appropriate which is great and i didn't
go into a hospital and
hopefully the vaccine had something to
do with that because i did wait on a
line
but the efficacy of the vaccine is
there's there's some debate about it
uh doctors tell me that
people that are having adverse reactions
to the virus that are doing very poorly
doing bad in the hospital
are largely unvaccinated however for
older people and if you look at the
studies coming out of israel uh it i
don't know how much of a difference it
makes a lot of vaccinated people are
still going to the hospital after you
hit a certain age group
um
and then there's the debate you know
jimmy kimmel made a joke should
unvaccinated people get uh beds in uh
the hospital and then glenn greenwald's
like should obese people get beds in the
hospital and you know
so that's where we are we are uh it's
the great vaccine debate of 2021
uh the final quarter of 2021
jimmy kimmel implies vaccinated heart
attack victims should get priority over
unvaxxed ivermectin slugging covet
patients this is out of the daily news
also the media is pretending and we've
made fun of ivermectin it's fun it's fun
to make fun of everything but
ivermectin is not only a drug for horses
it's a drug for people yes it won a
nobel prize the media knows that and it
doesn't mean that it's more effective
than a vaccine i don't know i'm not a
doctor i don't i don't i you know
there's no evidence of that there's no
big studies that suggest that but there
are doctors who say hey it's a good idea
to take
um
i've remembered no one is by the way
pitch suicide
which is fascinating to me that is the
most effective way to end to not be
hospitalized for covet 19 is to kill
yourself that is a 100 efficacy rate uh
if you have covert and you don't want to
be hospitalized you can take your own
life
not one person has said that howard
stern is in trouble he rips anti-vaxx
hosts who died of
covet
this is why you can't go too hard at the
vax because then you could die and it's
embarrassing i say the vex mandate is no
good i'm against compelling people to do
uh things
uh when when it doesn't even make sense
in terms of uh protecting society as a
whole you know this doesn't make any
sense um
but this is why you can't go too hard at
the facts because a lot of those guys
that went very hard at it died three and
one months yeah three in one minute it's
kind of an embarrassing death mr
anti-vaccine
it's a little embarrassing like a lot of
those guys made songs like about yeah
it's a little embarrassing
you know
it'll be embarrassing when megan mccain
kills me
will be embarrassing these are but if
you go out on a limb if you stake a
claim
um
if you say this is my turf i'm the
anti-vaxx guy you gotta survive
like candace owens you gotta she's gotta
survive
if she goes down it's going to look bad
you know
you don't want to hand people the
ammunition you want to hand people those
you don't know how the [ __ ] you're going
to react to this don't hand people that
ammunition
you don't need to there's no reason for
it
but let's also not pretend that this uh
vaccina rollout has been incredibly it's
at least everything we make as a country
is not really that good
truly
everything it's not just this
the idea that it's just the vaccine most
of what you get in america is [ __ ] now
most of it is [ __ ]
so of course pfizer is gonna be like
lowering your expectations every hour
about what the vaccine does
we get it you know it's it's garbage
yes is it good to get depending on who
you are
sure
but
it doesn't seem to last that long
they're already talking about boosters
it's like if you were buying a house and
in the middle of that deal the realtor
starts going in on your next house you
go focus
what are we doing
why don't you [ __ ] focus
but they keep talking about the booster
you're trying to get people vaccinated
with this [ __ ] dose that's like
barely working and then you start going
on about the booster people start going
wait a minute what's going on does this
even work
no it's the booster
no but next time we get it we get it on
the third shot the fourth shot we'll
figure it out we don't know it's
experimental and it also doesn't make
you feel great that obviously the
appearance of the booster signifies how
experimental this all is like it's one
thing to be a guinea pig it's another
thing to feel like a guinea pig you know
when they're like yeah we're gonna throw
the booster and see what happens
you go wait a minute what yeah we go we
do the booster now
around the holidays we'll line everybody
up for the book for the booster and see
what happens that does not make you feel
stunningly confident
in what's going on i just so i don't
these mandates i don't quite get
i can understand encouraging people to
get it i think it makes sense and a lot
of people
uh should get it uh there are certain
people that i understand why they didn't
get it if i spent my life working on my
body and my health uh maybe i wouldn't
get it but i haven't
spent my life doing that i've spent my
life getting funny and brilliant and
that doesn't lend itself always uh to
the preservation of the physical form
this is not my fault
if i was like a surfer with an eight
pack and i don't want to kill a surfer
with an eight pack out there if they're
hearing this
you know but if you're a surfer with an
eight pack and you're like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i'm not taking this hey man
whatever
you know
if you're like a fat slob from missouri
you know i don't know
maybe give it a shot
but the idea that it's a
one-size-fits-all
israeli study finds third shot provides
significant boost what does it mean
though all of these things stop using
the word boost that's not scientific
that's something a drug dealer tells you
you get a boost
what does this do it's a significant
boost what the [ __ ] does that mean in
numbers give me facts give me data give
me a percentage give me some idea here
pfizer's just thrown out fun language
you know
the booster is serving up fierce
realness
what
pfizer's just using this weird [ __ ]
language you know
pfizer is really [ __ ]
serving corona with fierce
[ __ ] you mrna realness
give us
the data
on that booster
because i've had it
i've beaten it and i've been vaccinated
i think i'm done can i and i had it
earlier i think i think we all think
i've had it twice enough already with
this
can we stop
can we just stop
you better come to my house pfizer i'm
not going to you
if you want me to get the booster come
to my house and put the needle in my
taint
and if you will do that i will get the
booster
i will do it
you will walk into my house and
sometimes you'll see this on craigslist
people get off like this i will be
blindfolded
in my living room
spread eagle
on a couch
you will come in
not speak to me they specify this a lot
of times on craigslist do not speak to
me
don't tell me who you are
you will then just deliver the needle in
the taint and leave
i will get up and unblindfold myself
only and after i hear you have left
the mystery
it will make it more fun
someone told me that once a guy
that i knew told me and i was terrified
when he said that to me because i enjoy
uh also because he had a wife but he
goes i enjoy uh sometimes when i'm tied
i someone comes in i have a blindfold on
i don't know who they are they [ __ ] me
and then leave the house
and i said well okay
and he goes sometimes i get [ __ ] with
a gun in my head and sometimes i dress
up like a woman
and uh i had no idea i was just sitting
there and i was kind of stunned i had a
face like
and they just said he goes i've never
told anyone that but i've chosen to
share it with you i said well that's
lovely
thank you so much i have to go now i was
at my own house i'm like i have to go
i must leave but thank you
thank you for confiding in me are you
vaccinated
it's the next line i say all right what
vaccine did you get because i like
getting [ __ ] with a gun to my head and
what vaccine did you get
that's the way you change the subject
now you just switch to vaccines no
matter what anyone says
i like getting [ __ ] by random
strangers that hold a gun to my head
and are you vaccinated i remember at the
time you guys wore social distancing in
the house when you said that it was very
funny
it was one of the most terrifying nights
of my life
i called you and you said
uh now that he's told you this do you
think he'll try to kill you
and then i said well i didn't think so
but maybe now yes i don't know
crazy
but
this is what uh
this is what people do let's take a look
at this uh hokey pokey video
you want to talk about
ev the news right now by the way
is there anything more disturbing than
the news trying to do feel-good stories
like i
am one of these people that go the news
is too negative but then you go outside
and you you realize
that it's kind of accurate it doesn't
mean their targets are you know always
valid or
but there's a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening
so
now here's how i measure how much [ __ ]
up [ __ ] is happening not even the
negative stories which we all know
already or the um
panic you know the news is always in a
panic about everything
it is what is crazier than the negative
choice is the feel good stories
have gotten
so bad
and so insane
that you genuinely
because this is all they got
this is all they have to take your mind
off the plague and the impending
economic collapse the eviction
moratorium people living in their cars
violence in the street gun to your head
at lunch we'll show you that video later
people eating lunch on the street gun in
your head armed robbery take your money
riots corrupt uh politicians
corrupt police everything in order to
take your mind off that they go to the
feel good uh stories and the bag of
stories that they pick are so disturbing
in in fact they're actually more
disturbing
than the hell that we're all used to by
now we're all used to the hell by now 27
years old healthy coven dead
in an hour
i mean that's all the stories they do
about kova they're like he was a
personal trainer and he ran up the
mountain every day he rescued dogs and
he had a beautiful wife and child and
now he's dead
covered and you're like [ __ ] and you
look at the guy he's ripped he's on like
a mountain he's got a beautiful wife
he's got three kids and a dog it looks
weirdly photoshopped i'm like does he
exist is this real
but who knows and it probably is but you
know we we're all used to that right now
we're all used to that horrible like
auto fatalities we're all used to like
you know
street racing like someone's just
sitting in a light and then these two
demon children
street racing just kill that person and
that person like you know it'll it'll be
like she was waiting to make a left into
the you know parking lot of a walgreens
and two street racers killed her and her
baby
and so you're used to that you're like
[ __ ] but you're used to it it makes
sense you go yeah
yeah
that's that
random acts of violence we get it
you know
waffle house brawls we we
but the feel-good stories
have become so insane and disconnected
from reality
that they are now more troubling you
find yourself staring at them and the
news doesn't even know how to do a
positive story anymore
first of all they all almost
they all the feel-good stories involved
people dying or about to die
just to give you an idea of
the feel-good stories they involve
terminal disease or the elderly
those are the that's the feel-good hour
that's the happy minute at the end like
a make-a-wish kid something like that
something like that
or or you know we all know the one where
it's like he walked 30 miles every day
to work
and everybody bought him a saturn
we got everyone in his job to donate you
know fifty dollars and we bought him a
used saturn that when it breaks down he
can't even get parts for cause they
don't make saturn's anymore he'll be
walking again in no time but put it and
let's make it go viral on facebook
because it's still a great country where
we care about our workers happy labor
day we all know that story right like
this person had no shoes they'd be like
this person had no shoes and instead of
going why do they not have shoes right
are they they work every day why do they
not have a car you're supposed to go
well all's well that ends well he got a
[ __ ] 1998
saturn
and he'll be thrilled now
um
but play this
feel-good story because this is about
uh i'm not even gonna tell you what it's
about let's just enjoy this together
i'll periodically stop it to try to
explain to you what's going on because
i've watched it several times this is
the good people at where cbs i think
this is cbs evening these are the good
people at the cbs evening news trying to
take your mind off all of the other
horrors with this piece of fun and light
which by the way this is heavier than
anything i've ever seen
[Music]
opinions vary when it comes to music one
person hears a symphony another person
hears noise but cbs's steve hartman
discovered a song that can get a whole
neighborhood dancing here's tonight's on
the road
on the road you're ready
already you know it's rough
on the road never means anything good
right
on tonight's on the road that means like
we're really out there that's cbs's way
of saying we are out there
in the sticks
this is how much contempt they have for
people that don't live in like l.a or
new york
they're like on the road and by on the
road we mean
somewhere in hell
we're broadcasting somewhere in hell on
the road you know where people are just
eating each other's corpses we've sent
one of our reporters out there to bring
you a story that is completely insane
dancing days are done phyllis
brinkerhoff of prairie village kansas
says she's not too old to appreciate a
sick beat
in fact mrs b as she's known in the
neighborhood is obsessed with one dance
song in particular it's just a fun
joyous song you put your right arm in
the hokey pokey
and you know how when you love a song
you want your friends to love it too
well that's why mrs b gave her neighbor
melanie mendry's a hokey pokey cd and
started talking about the song so this
is in kansas it's an old one i can see
her name pop up i'm obsessed with them
and i just thought oh
and it is
it's probably like a member of the fred
phelps church
like this woman they're probably
conveniently leaving out that like she
protested like marine funerals
with the god hates [ __ ] sign on oak tag
for the majority of her life in kansas
but now but listen to this she's
obsessed with the hokey pokey so this is
the feel-good story at cbs they found a
woman
who is
mentally ill
and obsessed with in a very annoying
song for children
the hokey pokey
she can't get enough of it
she's insane
they found an insane woman
who's obsessed with the hokey pokey
continue this it's the hokey pokey
hi this is phyllis mrs b left dozens of
messages
i really do need to talk to you urgently
pleading her case
cd i gave you are you hooked on it yet
and i just would always say not quite
yet
melanie's respect this woman
this old bat
gives this neighbor a cd of the hokey
pokey and then harasses her
and keeps calling her and goes are you
hooked on the hokey pokey yet
this is a story
that's supposed to make you feel good
about the direction of the country this
old bat
gives this woman a hokey pokey cd cause
she's like an mk ultra victim or
something this is a crazy behavior it's
crazy behavior
and then she calls this woman repeatedly
harassing her and her child going are
you hooked on it yet are you listening
are you listening
i mean this is like the behavior of
sirhan surhan who was activated to kill
bobby kennedy probably by the hokey
pokey they started playing that he
blacked out and then he came to in the
kitchen of the ambassador hotel standing
over a corpse
me and ray were laughing so hard they're
like ethel kenny what are the older
kennedys i forget maybe not ethel
somebody wrote a letter to keep sarah
and sohan in prison that's all the
kennedys have left now he's trying to
keep this old [ __ ] prison this old
patsy that's all they have left trying
to keep this old patsy in jail
let's continue this feel-good bit
baffled mrs b
you know most people don't care really
at all for the hokey pokey
really
i find that very amazing do you
still she knew her crusade was all but
lost
then one day mrs b happened to mention
that her birthday was coming up her 93rd
and when melanie heard that she decided
to embrace what she'd been resisting
or to put it in hokey pokey parlance
she put her whole self in
we made copies of the invitation we
rolled them in little scrolls and we
wrapped ribbons around them and traipsed
traipse stepping down the street you put
your whole self and now they have the
fattest they have more videos
this is a feel-good story about america
by the way they went through the
neighborhood in kansas
they have all these people who can't see
their feet
on the lawn
and they all can't do the hokey pokey
they can't even do a child's dance
these are the citizens of america
and they've all come to dance for this
old witch
she's doing some black magic ceremony
uh in her front yard and these tubs of
lard can't even get the hokey pokey
right
and this is and just finish this but
again this is supposed to make you feel
like we're on the right track and our
you know things aren't that bad you got
an antifa member far left here can you
see that
the blue haired little girl
no i don't oh yeah yeah it's a blue hair
the blue-haired girl in kansas they get
while here they get wild over there
let's see the rest of this
the smile on her face was so big
it doesn't take that much
to make someone's day
and i think we could all do a little
more of it shut up because of that look
at this what's next retired flight
attendant honors colleagues killed on 9
11.
these are the good stories
this is the fun this is cbs retired
flight attendant honors people killed on
9 11.
30 seconds yeah
they've devoted 30 seconds to this
that's 30 too much
can we play this can we yeah
well tonight a retired flight attendant
is on a mission to honor the flight
crews killed in the september 11th
attacks
paulie veneto is walking more than 200
miles from boston where united flight
175 took off from on the morning of the
attacks to one world trade center and
he's pushing a beverage cart along his
three-week journey
holly actually knew some of the crew
members who were killed and he wanted to
honor them
to raise money for the families of 9 11
victims
thank you paulie
yeah that's good thank you paulie good
luck
well there's that that's a feel-good
story that's uh happening better help is
something getting in the way between you
and your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals
i get sad sometimes you know that oh
yeah yeah and when i'm sad i spin it
into brilliant comedy that everyone can
appreciate you are not able to do that
so what's going to keep you on this
planet is a great counselor online
counseling and better help it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas the
services available for clients all over
the world
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video
or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic mattress so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
you need in fact so many people have
been using better help they're
recruiting more counselors been in all
50 states wow
the podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com tmd
it helps the show if you do this so go
to betterhelp.com tim d you're sad go to
betterhelp.comtimd i think betterhelp
help folks this summer love has come to
an end and i don't know if that ever
came true the summer of hope uh didn't
really materialize but that being said
it's gonna be the fall of [ __ ] i'm
telling you right now cut more than one
hole in that pumpkin uh blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers uh
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost you could take them
any time day or night you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done online
so no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are
unit made in the usa and prepared and
shipped directly to your door in a
discrete package
i love blue chew i take it and not even
for sex i just sometimes like to take it
and look at my penis throughout the day
blue chew is great everyone i know takes
it men women it's great they are made in
the usa and prepared shipped directly to
your door in a discreet package it's
time to get off the couch and go back to
work if your tool needs an upgrade head
to bluetooth.com
so if you could benefit from confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help we've got a special deal for all of
our listeners pl try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code td at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code tvtd to receive
your first month free bluetooth.com for
more deals and important safety
information and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast
let's uh go into this uh
brazen robbery
uh in the fairfax
melrose yeah yeah because this is also
the la recall coming up gavin new feudal
lord wine merchant gavin newsom going up
against uh larry elder
uh for the recall black conservative
larry elder who suggests that not only
slaves but slave owners also maybe
should get a little bit of reparations
okay here it is right here so now this
is
uh people outside in l.a
getting a gun to their head while
they're eating lunch and robbed and i go
am i for this i don't know but it's
crazy
we had lunch today we ate inside
because of this
because by the way it's also
embarrassing
to get
robbed at gunpoint while you're having
lunch
it's embarrassing
here's why it's too on it's like two
like this is very
like here's what's great about this
you know
during this lunch
someone said
something about
people exaggerating the crime
like there's no chance that during this
lunch someone didn't pop up and go
and i voted of course no on the recall
for newsome because quite frankly they
do this all the time they exaggerate the
crime they try to make you scared and
then gun to the temple
that's a little beautiful
if you think about that so let's take a
look at this this is in broad daylight
in the fairfax district of los angeles
this is
a guy in a hoodie
and someone else they look like tick
tockers
these are old vine stars who didn't
transition into tick tock
some of the old vine stars are broke now
they might as well start robbing people
with guns
what if this is the demilio sisters
like they listened to the last podcast
and they agreed with me and they're like
we got to start going out there and
[ __ ] [ __ ] up how many people do we
know that this could and should be them
oh yeah we know so many people who
should be holding people up and we don't
even know why they're not
unemployment just ended i mean i guess
they're gonna start
but uh this is a foursome and then they
put the gun
guns right to the old noggin
let's take a look at that one more time
they're just having lunch
oh my god have you seen white lotus oh
no
the guy has his hands up it's like that
seems to be a little
let's see what she's saying what's
what's what's what anne suiter what's
going on anne eyewitness news reporter
leanne suter live in the melrose
district with new reaction and the
manhunt happening right now leanne
martin
as bold and brazen as you can get area
residents and business owners say this
type of crime is happening all too
a often robbery in broad daylight on
melrose
right at the end
of the robbery
shopping bags and belongings on the
table
wow
[Music]
i live in this neighborhood and hang out
all the time
a popular strip full of stores and
restaurants many business owners say
they have been seeing crime
increasingly i think that it's just
that like it's just racist
so i don't really talk about it but like
wow
it's crazy
broad daylight and here's the thing with
gavin newsom i like watching rich
attractive people get nervous he's
getting a little nervous because of this
recall here's the thing with gavin
newsom people say he's very liberal and
the the reality of the situation is i
bet he's not that liberal and what i
mean by that is i don't think he really
believes in anything he's just kind of a
good-looking rich wine merchant who
walks around his vineyard like a feudal
lord drunk on cabernet he has no idea
what's going on
the california state legislature is
locked up with a lot of people that
don't want anything to happen largely
democrats of course um but i mean again
this guy is not he didn't know what
governor was before he got the job he
just thought he would go out to dinner
he just wants to drink barolo with his
hot wife he does not want to deal with
he doesn't know what ms-13 is i don't
even think he's been to l.a like he
lives up north
i mean he just wants to go to dinner
with his friends in montecito like when
you saw him at the french laundry that
was the happiest he'd ever been because
he was at dinner he's like thank [ __ ]
god finally we can go to dinner at a
great restaurant and drink wine
i mean
this state
is so ungovernable
i mean you you run for governor of
california you're like this is gonna be
fun it can't be that hard arnold
schwarzenegger did it i'm good-looking
my wife's at peace we like wine people
like us i'm the la governor look at me i
don't look like andrew cuomo or any of
these other like bombs like i'm the la
governor i'm in shape i'm into the wine
business i'm i'm about all that [ __ ] and
then your first day you're like sitting
at the desk and it's like traffic fires
machete beheading ms-13
droughts killings all the movie studios
are leaving hollywood's dead traffic
beheadings machete malibu death rain no
rain drought fires flood and you're like
what the [ __ ]
new scientology building yeah i mean
it's crazy you know
there's a there's a you know there's the
homeless who just built a hotel out of
shopping carts on sunset it's what do
you do
how do you lead how do you govern this
state i mean good luck to larry elder i
don't think he'll get anything done
either because it's just ungovernable
how do you even fix it
the amount of problems the scope of them
is is there's so many
but you know that gavin newsom doesn't
want to he doesn't want it kevin newsom
listen is he ineffective yes
uh is he left center sure but like look
at him he doesn't care about homeless
people not at all he just you know
ship him to montecita do we have can we
get an interview of him even speaking
oh yeah let's i don't know i mean have
you watched him this guy
is like not even present in his own body
this has got to be him speaking here
yeah yeah here we go here he goes
to make history of our own here in the
state of california
by rejecting that city of the city that
well that's cynicism rejecting that fear
rejecting that kind of divisiveness
california we are better than that we
have the opportunity you see what he did
the other day because larry elder said
men understand things better than women
and gavin's like no women do and then
anahashan from red scary retweeted some
guy who writes yeah women run california
that's why it's on fire and everybody's
lives in a tent it's kind of hilarious
but you know i mean this guy is not this
is empty
i mean i think ezra klein is like a you
know liberal guy at vox wrote
uh that california's kind of a failure
of progressive governance i don't know
that larry elder's gonna help i think he
could throw a i was backing caitlyn
jenner's i wanted a little fun
i wanted a little fun i wanted her to
get her escalade and just mow
uh the homeless over which was her plan
she wrote a plan
that the la times refused to publish
where it was literally just a route that
she would take her escalade through
venice
knocking over homeless encampments
and they refused
gavin newsom is much more oh no this is
not what i said uh this was ezra eight
days ago but he also uh ezra also wrote
this
is this
he wrote california's making liberal
squirm and it's a failure of progressive
governance but now he goes uh
uh gavin newsom is a lot more than
lesser at two evils
here's the california is not as bad it
is bad right i mean it's not good but
it's not as bad
as you would think
you know certain parts of it are they
they're trying
here
uh they're losing the one industry that
california has made california relevant
has traditionally been the entertainment
business
and now it is the tech industry
that is is you know headquartered up in
san fran palo alto
that is the new dominant industry in the
state
but it was hollywood for a very long
time a lot of movie studios are leaving
they're abandoned in california it is
too expensive it is not cost effective
to shoot here they're going to atlanta
and a lot of them are going to canada
they're moving
and hollywood is
you know is losing
a lot of the
uh bigger studios i mean they're fleeing
so california's trying to
stop that they're trying to stop the
bleeding they're trying to stop that
mass exodus because it is the only
industry
outside of tech
that
really
the majority of the los angeles economy
is kind of a lot of it is based on that
it's really an import export town i
don't want to say the majority that
might be the wrong way to say it
but it's it's the reason that people
have uh lived here and it represents
billions and billions of dollars in
revenue to the state a lot and they're
losing a lot of that
um
and i don't know how they're going to
plan to do it and this has been
happening for years it's been happening
for years it's very expensive here to
shoot things
and the internet has given people the
ability to attract an audience outside
of the mainstream system of networks and
studios we've done it and a lot of
people we know have done it it's why
they hate joe rogan so much because he's
done it
so
you know a lot of people are don't have
to be in california and they don't have
to even if they are here they don't need
to rely on a staff of 20 or 30 or 50 or
100 people
they can do things um
you know very simply so you wonder
because the the industry is having such
a
an evolution
what does that mean
long term for california but i think
what what happens is just hollywood is
replaced by
the tech industry which seems to have
some permanence here even though new
tech companies are many of them go into
austin and there's some big people down
there but it seems like because you have
stanford here a lot of the tech
companies are always going to be
anchored
in california and a lot of revenue is
going to be coming from that not to the
people but to the state
because these companies do not employ a
lot of people tech companies famously
employ
very few people
uh
as opposed to companies like general
motors or something like that but they
have a lot more power they have more
power than any companies have ever had
before they know everything about you
they know what you think and believe
what you're afraid of what you search
for they know what you do and what you
watch they know uh where you bank and
how you bank and what you buy and they
can
uh turn
any of this off they can turn your
ability to talk often your ability to
stop spending money really i mean you
know this thing where like candace owens
was refused to covet test and uh you
know they shut off alex jones's uh debit
card and you might hate these people but
you should recognize that corporations
being able to deny services to people
based on politics is probably a bad
thing
right
shouldn't we agree with that
that being able to turn off someone's
money supply
or refuse them a test to see if they get
tested for covid which they could if
they had
spread to other people
denying them that based on pod is just
not good how bad will this get
like how bad is this gonna get
are we gonna is it is it is it gonna be
a thing where like
the unvaccinated people go to in and out
and the vaxxed people go to fat burger
is that
how divisive this country is going to
get
i want to know how divisive this country
is going to get
are certain porn sites
going to sp make you
scan your qr vax code before you jerk
off to a woman getting drowned in a fish
tank
how bad is it gonna get out there
are gun stores
not gonna sell you an ar if you're vax
like a puss
how bad is it gonna get
truly
are you still gonna be able
to get a mcgriddle
at three o'clock in the morning if you
are unvaccinated
is denny's
going to have two sections one for
vaccinated people
and one for unvexing how bad does this
get how divisive
this is becoming a caste system the
biggest subreddit right now is herman
cain award have you seen this it's blown
up massively why but it's people kind of
celebrating the uh
deaths of
here's the thing i'll preface it by
saying it is funny to see someone post
eight things about how they'll never get
the vaccine and then they die and then
they like die tragically and then you
know you gotta find the humor where you
find it
so like this is i've been long listen
all we have left in this country is to
celebrate the deaths of our political
opponents i've been a fan of that if i
die people will dance on my grave uh
whatever this is and
it's not even that i'm like
this hugely divisive character but i've
angered some so the the deal is you're
allowed to do that i think within reason
that something that you should be
allowed to do is to celebrate the deaths
of your political opponents because you
don't have health care you don't have a
retirement
you probably you know your family if you
have one may hate you
so because you know
things
are rough
um you should be able to celebrate the
deaths of people you disagree with and
the right does it and the left does it
more texas love it wife gloats she makes
a local news for protesting covent
mandates catches covet almost dies
husband gets coveted and dies and now
she needs money because she's a single
mom covert long-hauler no thanks i'll
burn my money before i do that there's
something here
that's biblical about all of this
there's something biblical about all
this we're failing the test
of of compassion for both sides by the
way for every everybody is uh failing
we're we're we're we're
450 000 people in sturgis rally not a
china virus super spreader stop living
in fear and get back to the and what
happens is this guy and then he dies
yeah then these people they go through
facebook and they find all these posts
like i'll never get the vaccine i have
an immune system i don't need a vaccine
and then they die and then their page
turns into a memorial page because they
just died of covenant yeah but here's
the thing where does this end
this is my question if you're really
getting excited about this and i know
some of you are and i've don't get i've
just defended your right
to be excited by this is it a great way
to spend your time probably not look
what did this guy say not trying to win
any pageant but i'm alive and doing
better oxygen is improving by the day i
feel better as a whole getting moved out
of icu sometime in the morning thank you
all for your thoughts and prayers they
mean the world to me so please keep them
coming what happened this was the same
guy he then he died but then they keep
you updated on facebook after sharing
memes every day that are anti-vaxxed and
then they just die
from yeah
but this would also be like if you found
people that did get vacs and either went
to the hospital and died you could do
that too sure
this is not a real productive use of the
time no but this is blown up people love
it people like it
listen people like
to go and find
people that
have died
um and
try to catch them
i mean this is like something
this is like something my aunt would do
you know after because she's now going
on with the women in afghanistan that
she's all worried about now after not
caring about them for 20 years now she's
all uh she's cause i can't believe these
women in afghanistan cia men you got to
hand it to them it really works
everything they do works the propaganda
machine works by boomerang it's like but
the women in afghanistan but what about
if they want to learn to play the violin
um
i think probably
you should try to not
enjoy
the deaths of others too much
this is a
now i've defended your right to do it
and i understand why you're doing it but
it it seems to be
a very dark way to spend your time
it's it's weird there's something karma
wise about it that i think is weird
like if i spent all my time laughing at
the deaths of people that i disagreed
with
i would feel there's some weird karma to
that
that is gonna swing back around my
direct
you know
i just
i think it's odd
to do that but i i understand why people
are doing it
i get it
if a bunch of vaccinated people
started dying
would it not be the other way
right and there have been vast people
that have died but it would be because
because people enjoy
when vaccinated people go to the
hospital
they go see
[Music]
it's both way see this is where country
of sea now
see
look at them they're trying to breathe
they're flopping around like a fish
we've become a country of people that
enjoy
uh the deaths of what this is the final
stage you know it's the final stage of
of what we're whatever we're trying to
do here and i know that you know people
tend to
think i'm maybe being dramatic or i'm
overstating things i actually think i've
been
too positive
uh and i framed this issue
in a comedic way
more often than not but to truly take a
break from that for a minute which also
has is funny in a way um
this is really the final stage
before we descend into just barbarism
this is the final stage before uh
barbarism will take hold
uh because people are getting off
watching other people die
think of where we started we liked
ratting each other out
that was the start of it we're like it's
fun to rat and tell people what to do
and everybody got on everybody's back
and everybody was like did you go out
who have you seen
are you fat did you have an abortion
like everybody has become everyone
else's mother
father keeper
governor uh you know people just people
like it they like petty
uh
you know
uh excuses so that they can be moralists
and they can you know lord their power
over other people it started there and i
warned against that i said it's a very
bad idea it's a very bad idea to
encourage people ratting on each other
uh and feeling superior morally to each
other
a little over a year later we are now
openly enjoying each other's deaths
and hospitalization and suffering like
batman we are enjoying each other's
deaths and hospitalizations
we're posting them
we're saying ha ha
we're saying look at this the news is
getting in on it the media is saying
look at this they ran a million articles
about that guy phil valentine
it's unhealthy this is bad energy it's
bad karma it's yes should you have the
right to do it sure but it just to tell
you
karma wise not good this isn't what we
should be doing it's the final phase
before we start killing each other
there's really nothing left to do we're
enjoying each other's deaths already
the next thing will just be to make
those deaths happen
which will be the final final phase
of this
but it doesn't seem like a great idea i
talk
people all the time
are giddy
about the death of someone or you know
you'll talk to somebody go yeah he was
faxed he can't breathe now
and you go
okay man it's like socks we don't know
what's going on
yeah he can't even breathe he's fighting
for his life and they say it like they
just tell you their kid got into college
he's fighting for his life isn't that
nice and then on the other side you know
if somebody who's unvaxxed dies of covet
and they were like didn't want to get
the vaccine and they were public about
that i mean they just they do a [ __ ]
conga line on the guy's grave it's
really wild to watch
where we are instead of just here's what
i do when you say tell me someone died i
don't even ask ready okay because
someone died at coven uh my friend died
a coven
[ __ ] is [ __ ]
next i mean that's you don't
i don't
here's what here's what other people do
were they faxed were they fattened
what'd they do
what was their name like how'd they get
it where they get to bar did they get
did they go out
were they fat
did they eat bread
did they take 19 supplements
did they get the monoclonal antibodies
were they vast
did they take the nad drips did they
take vitamins did they go in the sauna
how old were they
did they go out did they see friends
that they won two or three masks
were they in anti-massacre who gives a
[ __ ] they're dead move on
they're dead move on
you become a district attorney when you
hear that someone died now
you try to get to the bottom of it you
know
it's it's alarming
it's just
it's just alarming
but we can always count on cbs to have
those feel good stories
about people get out of this here i'm
sick of this get out of this this is
it's bad for us even to look at
it's crazy how fast the price is of
everything a rising gas groceries closed
you name it
and all the experts are saying it's
gonna get worse before it gets better
i've been looking at all the ways you
can personally cut out costs to save
where you can i started my own i used
gabby auto insurance what i was able to
do is put in all my information and
compare in real time
quotes to get the same coverage i have
now for less
on average people that use gabby save
like
80 a month wow i mean that adds up
right yeah that's a lot of money it's
almost a thousand dollars a year
it's a lot
and by the way there's no commitment
they don't sell your info
you just get fast verifiable quotes not
ballpark guesses it is a great thing to
use if you're not happy with your car
insurance and who is
it's not just me who loves gabby gabby's
been featured in tech crunch forbes usa
today start saving on your auto
insurance today go to gabby.com tim
dillon to start saving today it's
totally free that's g-a-b-i dot com tim
dillon gabby.com tim dillon it's so
important right now to go over all of
your expenditures and see if you can
save and gabby allows you to do that no
commitment no cost
gabby
now it's time to celebrate the nfl is
finally back and draftkings the official
uh the official daily fantasy partners
of the nfl has millions of reasons why
you should be excited to kick off
football season draftkings is giving new
customers a free shot at 1 million top
prize with a total of 4 million dollars
up for grabs at thursday is opener
getting in on thursday night's single
game show is easy draft six players from
the season opener stand to the salary
cap and see how your team stacks up
against the competition so head to the
app now feel the nfl action like never
before with a free shot and a million
dollar payday download the draftkings
app now use the code tim dillon do it if
you like this show
and you're a degenerate gambler or
you're a fun gambler
this week new customers can get a free
shot at the one million dollar top prize
four million in total prizes enter code
tim dillon you will get a free shot at
one million dollar top prize with your
first deposit that's code tim dillon
only at draftkings the official daily
fantasy partner of the nfl minimum five
dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftking.com for
details
the detroit news parents lose lawsuit
over destruction of son's porn stash and
good [ __ ] these
people read a little bit of this this is
a great story now this is a feel-good
story this is yeah yeah um there's a 40
year old man who lives at home he lives
at home as he should but to be fair he
hasn't always lived at home he had a
divorce and he moved back in with his
parents yeah on his feet fair and then
when he moved out they had destroyed
close to thirty thousand dollars they
described twelve boxes worth of
pornography and he and he took them to
court anyone any one anyone
well they destroyed property
yep
i don't uh on new year's day 2018
according to the suit working's father
sent him an email that said i don't
think that you've been listening to me
so let me make this very clear i do not
possess your pornography it is gone it
has either been destroyed or disposed of
i may well have missed a few items that
are now in your possession but at this
point if you don't have it it is gone
ditto for your sex toys and smutty
magazines we counted 12 moving boxes
full of porn plus two boxes of sex toys
we began the day pro process of
destroying them and it took quite a
while to do so frankly david i did you a
big favor by getting rid of all that
well this is a confession
his father is confessing
the next month working called the ottawa
county sheriff and a deputy spoke with
his mother who acknowledged a couple of
dispose of the pornography on march 17th
according to the complaint she sent her
son an email saying believe it or not
one reason for why i destroyed your porn
was for your own mental and emotional
health
working's parents said they had a right
to act as his landlord defenders do not
cite any statute or caseload to support
their assertion that landlords can
destroy property they dislike the judge
said maloney told both sides to file
briefs on the financial value of the
collection
the court does not intend to hold an
evidentiary hearing so what's the uh
oh you got 38 000.
the parents had to pay him 38 38 yeah 38
grand
i mean having kids can really go one of
two ways
right yeah
it can work out
or it can really be like [ __ ] what did
we do
and when your kid is paying when you're
paying 30k
to your son
because you threw out his sex toys
there's got to be a part of you that
regrets having children
like all these people in texas that are
anti-abortion don't you understand this
is how it could work out your 40 year
old loser son could move back into your
house and [ __ ] pocket [ __ ] and then
leave and leave his porn stash here you
get rid of it because you're horrified
by it imagine like you're you're sifting
through your sons like pocket [ __ ]
and dildos and whatever and his porn
collection whatever that guy's into that
ruined his first marriage you know
that's what ruined his first marriage
and they find it they go we're just
gonna get rid of this [ __ ] and then they
gotta cough up 30 thou
good it took him a day to destroy all
the porn that was the worst day of their
life
destroying all of your son's porn and
sex toys the great thing to me is two
boxes of sex toys that they knew he used
they knew they're picking up like
[ __ ]
pocket [ __ ] and
i mean it's just
that's a feel-good story like the news
gets it wrong i don't hear about some
old [ __ ] that wants to hear a song
this is a feel-good story imagining that
couple from canada having to sift
through their son's pocket [ __ ]
and then throw them out
you think there was a debate you think
one of them was like let's keep them for
him
you think it was any debate or both of
them were they were probably on the same
page i was like let's just get rid of
this
this ruined his life
you know the whole day they were
debating when he got into this he was
like was it a teeny were we not paying
attention
did this start as a teen you know this
ruined his marriage
and he's this is gonna ruin everything
he does he's a sex addict
he's addicted to porn
he's got all the sex toys we don't even
know what some of them do
but we know this we're getting rid of
them we're getting them the [ __ ] out of
this house we're doing him a big favor
and then a judge goes
30 grand
i needed to urinate woman as to leave
disney park for her behavior
this is another fun story
people do not know so here's the thing
since the pandemic
uh is is you know whatever wrapping up
now and people are going back out people
and we notice there's a comedy shows
people just don't know how to act they
don't know how to act they don't know
their limits they don't know how much
booze they can drink uh before they
start uh the room starts spinning and
they start vomiting they don't
understand uh what decorum is they don't
understand how they're supposed to act
like human beings so
what we notice is you know people in on
flights now are just beating the [ __ ]
out of flight attendants because they
don't realize that that is wrong
they haven't flown in a year and a half
they forget they go am i allowed to hit
the flight attendant
or not that guy duct taped on united was
groping all of the flight attendants
yeah cause people he hasn't flown in a
while he goes what is the rules here
again
can i finger the person bringing me
juice or not
they're unclear so now what happened at
disney world this woman was this was a
viral tick tock uh this woman is a uh
uh i'll
i'll reveal her occupation in the tick
tock right here but she uh she was
pissing in a cup in front of people at
disney she had to go yeah she had to go
it just says what it is but here here we
go because i have a bad bladder i don't
think you understand what women's
platters are all about but i really have
a bad blast
and there's no reason for you to
justify me or judge me i am not judging
you ma'am
you are sir no i'm not tom
someone higher up in the corporate chair
but i needed a yearning
so what's going on and i need to work so
right here there's been times where i
have to you'll see the card she tries
tom
i am a
i am a teacher a huge therapist that's
right i literally have to urinate in a
church therapist is not a teacher
because i don't have time to go to south
central right on slaughter
and cringe
to your needs that's where she lives
i cannot believe you're judging me i'm
not joking
do we see her peeing no no no this was
taken after but she was she was just
pissing in a cup and then she tried to
say since she's a teacher she should be
allowed she because i'm a speech
therapist i'm a lot of [ __ ]
i'm allowed to [ __ ] in a box i'm a
speech therapist um so what did they do
they threw her out of the park yeah they
threw out
they threw her right out there the only
report on it is from the tick tock but i
thought i don't know if i'm for that
she just pissed in a cup right she
didn't throw it in anyone's face no she
didn't throw it on anyone so what why
are we
i mean it's not even disney world it's
disneyland which is like not even real
disneyland is an embarrassment
disneyland is horrible
disney world is legit disney world
florida yeah disneyland anaheim oh i
mean disneyland at anaheim it's not even
real
it's like six flag i mean it's stupid
we're on tour folks you got to come see
us on tour we're very excited about
being out there for the rest of the year
um
just come see us we're at so many cool
places
timdylandcomedy.com again seattle
portland indianapolis morgantown west
virginia
mulln hall pennsylvania washington d.c
new york new york atlantic city new
jersey rochester new york iowa city iowa
madison wisconsin louisville kentucky
los angeles l.a bakersfield reading
pennsylvania atlanta georgia st louis
missouri fresno california sacramento
california san francisco garden city
idaho toronto ontario for new year's eve
uh spectacular we also have some uk
dates
we're going to announce very excited
going there for a week i believe in
january
we hope
and we believe
tim dilloncomedy.com is where you can
see the full tour schedule get tickets
promo code fake biz
uh we launch tomorrow monday
september 13th
at noon
noon eastern standard time eastern
standard time baby fake biz
promo code really excited to see you
guys
um on the road it should be a lot of fun
and uh we end this year together
don't enjoy people's deaths too much
it's like booze
drugs in small doses with close friends
and family
that's the way you should celebrate the
deaths of others
like
infrequently
with friends
not publicly
every now and then you you enjoy uh
someone's demise
but don't do it too frequently it's
ghoulish
it's ghoulish
if you keep doing it stop investigating
people's cova deaths like you're a
sleuth
well what what just realize this [ __ ]
affects people differently and sometimes
they go
and it sucks you don't have to go
through it and find out you know if they
were vacs to run facts or if they went
out they go to bars did they eat
mcgriddles hey man
life's life just kind of behave
just behave yourself
please
do you have anything to add you rarely
do
uh uh to the show
uh to anything
uh
i've been having a good time with you
here in la it's been fun have we uh the
the chocolate souffles were were
delicious and so what
they're very good
i like the souffles here
do you realize the content you bring is
horrible
like if we relied on you we'd be broke
i said you have anything to add you said
i like the cake that we had earlier
today
we'll go broke with that kind of
content
nobody wants that [ __ ]
he can't even he doesn't even have a
line at the end i go you have anything
for anybody and you go yeah the cake we
had was good the souffle cake was good
yeah thanks
that's clippable should that be the clip
everyone
should we put that out on social media
that ben likes the souffle that we had
they divide diet coke and everyone's
going to go we heard a souffle
you see
that's what happens
how's oscar de la hoya is he coming back
we can't lose oscar de la hoya
is he okay
oh released he's released there we go
but the fight's canceled
the fight is canceled
what are you gonna do
he'll be back
he'll be back what did he say go back up
said it hit him really hard
yeah
that's okay he'll be back does he have
brain fog can you tell anyway
kidding he's an athlete we know that you
know
i was in there for three days it hit me
really hard i was in the best shape of
my life
crazy
oh uh before we go did you see trump
said that robert e lee would have won
afghanistan
yeah i mean it's it's funny yeah it's
fine it's a funny line
how did his tour with bill o'reilly go
did they did that not they're doing it
in december
him and bill o'reilly they're doing it
in florida a couple dates in florida
that's it huh i believe so the tour kind
of bombed
yeah i mean
that's all right the q and on people
they thought he was going to become
president again that's okay it's like
this is just as good you get to spend
to seam in an arena and uh bill
o'reilly's opening
bill o'reilly the boomer rapist will be
opening
yeah they're doing the american airlines
center in dallas and
they're doing big venues i don't know if
he's a rapist but i will say this he's
uh you don't pay someone 38 million for
nothing oh have you read those court
transcripts with with bill well
yeah but i haven't read them like
recently is it just the luffa stuff
yeah like he would keep interns on the
phone and he would it's got to be more
he would ship them bags of toys and make
them yeah 38 million though it's got to
be more than that oh yeah right oh yeah
something else happened he like climbed
in a window 38 million
dude there's no [ __ ] way
i don't care how many bags of dildos you
shipped
you had to do something heinous
to part with that kind of money 40
sticks
40 million dollars
so he's opening
he's opening
and then i imagine he's not closing i
imagine no trump's to close or trump's
gonna go out and talk about
he's gonna be funny he's gonna do bits
this is what he should be doing he's on
the road
doing bits
the ex-president
just on the road
killing he'll kill for an hour
ticket sales are still moving slowly
well listen folks don't
spend the money to see me the tickets
are cheaper
and the show will be almost as good yeah
this is very expensive it's very
expensive
my show is almost as good as this and
it's cheaper i'm not gonna say it's as
good as i'm not gonna lie to you
i would go for bill o'reilly alone i'd
spend the 300 to just see to just see
like what bill o'reilly's even doing
like what is that opening set you know
what is that even about
but then of course we know trump's gonna
kill it but all right folks
timdylandcomedy.com um
don't rob me if you see me having lunch
in los angeles please at gunpoint
it's gonna be [ __ ] embarrassing
and if i get shot in the head while i'm
having lunch in los angeles you can
enjoy it for a day
that's it and then move on